[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Christian Schaefer I a
photographer and filmmaker and I'm now
in my sixth year of living on the road
fulltime in May of 2018 I moved out of
my apartment that was just outside of
Seattle Washington and into my niss
Sonic sta SUV for a summer which turned
into 14 months then I decided to
purchase this band which I've called
home for more than 4 years now I've
already done two complete walkthroughs
of my original build that you can go and
watch if you want to see just how this F
started out this video will be an
overall walkthrough but with emphasis on
the changes and updates I've made since
the rebuild if you've been following me
for a bit you know about what happened
this summer I just decided to start
ripping flooring up cuz I was smelling
some really concerning smells
and it's pretty bad guys most of the
subf flooring was soaked with water it
was a hugely stressful event I would not
wish it on anyone the problem was a leak
in the plumbing in a section between the
cabinet and the actual metal van floor
so in a place where the leak wasn't
visible and pretty much just went
unnoticed for a really long time and did
a lot of damage I contacted my original
Builder and we wound up ripping out the
entire bottom half of the van and doing
a total rebuild at this point it's
December so I've now been living in the
new remodel for about 4 months and I've
had some time to really test out the new
build this van is a ram promas High roof
1500 136 wheelbase with custom cut wheel
wells for 245 altering ko2 tires and
aftermarket Sumo springs for added
suspension for this rebuild we replac
the entire lower half of the B I did
consider a fixed bed this time around
but ultimately decided to keep the din
setup I love having the ability to
completely transform my living space
every day and the office setup makes it
much easier to edit for long stretches
of time at first glance it might look
kind of exactly the same but there are
quite a few changes we made to really
maximize space and make this band even
more functional than before
so one of the first things we did was
redesign the dimensions of this walkway
we widened it by 2 in and then we also
push the countertops in by 2 in so the
bed is a little bit Slimmer but the
trade-off is that I have a lot more
space in the hallway where I can easily
store my ebike and still get in and out
one thing you may have noticed is that
we got rid of the toe kick so the toe
kick it was in the previous build a 3-in
space where your toe could slide
underneath and you wouldn't stub your
toe all the time I decided to to get rid
of that in order to maximize space I
personally think it's been so worth it I
was able to add two more lithium
batteries in the electrical compartment
we made the camera drawer so much bigger
and there was so much extra space that
we just played with the dimensions over
here a little bit and added an entire
second drawer above the fridge I wanted
to repurpose and Salvage as much as
possible for this rebuild so we were
able to keep the upper cabinets all of
the lighting the fixtures appliances
even the subway tile is the same as the
original build we just regrouted
everything so that it's nice and bright
with the countertops I went with a
whiter brighter color I just feel like
the brighter the more opens the space up
up here we replaced the dtic fantastic
fan with the max a fan and honestly it
has been night and day the fantastic fan
I would only run when I was cooking
because I had to and the reason is
because it makes this loud woring sound
that was so annoying but this fan is
like feather light and I run it all
night long when I'm sleeping it puts me
right to bed this can be ran in the rain
whereas my old one couldn't so highly
recommend here is the camera drawer it
goes back further and it's deeper so I
can fit everything I need to in there if
you guys are interested in knowing what
camera care I use or what I have in my
office setup or even anything I
mentioned in this vour I have a page on
my website that's linked down below it's
everything from camping gear to camera
gear to Van life
Essentials here is the bottom drawer
where I just keep towels utensils
cutting boards and and then this drawer
on top is where I keep the rest of my
utensils I kept the same small dtic
fridge which in all honesty I would have
loved to go with a larger size just to
accommodate more food but that would
have meant selling the old fridge buying
a new fridge and this just seemed like
the simpler way to go if you saw my
previous van tour you might remember
that I had an 11 lb propane tank and I
actually never used that in the van I
had just gotten it for the van and
someone in the comments pointed out that
it wasn't properly ventilated and that
it was an actual safety hazard I ended
up going right back to the one PB
Coleman propane tanks which it really
sucks from an environmental perspective
because I go through them a lot more
often than I would a bigger propane
canister I did consider replacing this
gas stove with an induction stove top
but everything I read online just said
that it drew a lot of power I didn't
want to complicate things further by
adding in an appliance that would
require even more power so I am sticking
with the propane gas stove top for now
in this cabinet I have more food storage
mostly dry goods and these collapsible
cloth baskets bowls plates frying pan my
pot here and then I'll keep spices or
produce up in here the key is to make
sure it doesn't rattle when you're
driving and so far this has been pretty
solid in this cabinet I have more
kitchen storage kitchen supplies
toiletries more kitchen stuff
collapsible strainer favorite mugs
plastic wine glasses collapsible water
kettle which I use all the time every
day aerrow press for making coffee
behind those linen boxes I have my
propane tank and a propane gas detector
mounted behind that I have a bare bin
for whenever I'm camping in remote
locations and need to store trash
outside the vehicle down in this cabinet
is the electrical system everything in
this van is solar powered and runs off
of either AC or DC current for this
rebuild I decided to double the battery
capacity to four 100 amp lithium
batteries on the roof I have two mounted
solar panels that are 160 WT each so 320
WTS total and I use an app on my phone
to wirelessly monitor my battery levels
throughout the van there are five 12vt
dimmable light switches 10 LED 12volt
Puck lights three AC Outlets four USBC
and two USB charging ports with these
newer ports I'm able to power my laptop
using 140 W 12vt converter rather than
my inverter which definitely helps
conserve energy we move the fuse box to
the front so it's easier to access and
upgraded the DC DC charger to a solar DC
charging combo that charges my house
batteries whenever I drive this newer
model is both smaller and more efficient
it can recharge my setup to 100% with
roughly 8 hours of driving I also have a
3,000 W inverter and we upgraded the
wiring throughout to better support the
voltage I can curl my hair I can use
power
tools in this drawer we have maybe the
most important thing in the van which is
the the
toilet T if you guys remember in my last
B build my toilet was on a drawer with
actual sliders and it was constantly
falling apart I had to do multiple
repairs on it this design is a lot
simpler we made it to accommodate the
trino composting toilet which highly
recommend these two bins here on the
side are for trash and composting
material for the toilet I stack my
toilet paper here on the side so
everything is conveniently located for
me to use the bathroom number one and
number two in this cabinet I keep mostly
cleaning supplies this little shelf is a
new addition and under the sink is
basically more cleaning supplies compost
garbage bin baby wipes paper towels mini
plunger grocery bags minint Roller Magic
Erasers composting bag everyday cleaner
dish soap bear spray Swiffer glass
cleaner rodent spray very important
laundry detergent I got six of these in
2021 and I still have two left on the
inside of this cabinet door I have three
hooks to hang dish drying towels and my
mini broom that I use all day every day
we relocated the water pump from the
side of this cabinet to the top to make
better use of what was otherwise an
empty space Here's the water pump and
gray water tank switch and the gray
water tank is a 5 gallon tank stored
outside underneath the van out here is
my water storage so that I have easy
access to just take it out and fill it
up and of course we redid All of the
[Music]
plumbing
in my original build I had the shoe
drawer accessible from the outside which
honestly didn't make a lot of sense cuz
I couldn't get to my shoes unless I went
outside so we move this indoors and now
I use it every day when it came to
flooring for this rebuild I actually
found what I think is the exact same
flooring that I had in the original
build it was deeply discounted at Floor
and Decor so we love that we used the
same flooring all throughout including
underneath the benches in the back with
the ram pro masters there is a metal
flooring with grooves and in the past we
put in pieces of plywood to make it
everything level which ended up just
being one more material that could get
soaked so we eliminated that and we left
those channels open so that if there is
ever any water underneath the van it can
hopefully go out the back through those
open channels on top of the metal
flooring we put 1/8 in Mahogany which
was painted and treated to be mold and
milder resistant then we just glued
engineered hardwood flooring directly on
top of that in the old build we had the
plywood planks a four of an inch of
plywood a whole layer of insulation a
whole layer of cork and then engineered
hardwood actually curious to noce how
tall this is 6'2 I think it was only 510
maybe 511 last time this down here is
another new addition it's basically a
4in step that still allows me oh you
can't see there's still Headroom we made
the mistake of mismeasuring these
benches and my feet were d dangling and
end up being a really happy accident
because this is more storage and we love
more storage it is my tripod
storage up in these cabinets I keep
mostly clothing and they're stored in
these collapsible cloth bins I like to
roll most of my clothes just because it
maximizes storage and it's easier to see
what you have in this bin I have
zippered travel bags so I keep socks in
here underwear bras that sort of thing
keeps it really organized folded pants a
folding mirror and a bunch of toiletries
face wash face lotion contact solution
hairbrush makeup miscellaneous toiletry
stuff hair ties more toiletry stuff I
got these little containers off of
Amazon and I store various things in
them like this one has sunscreen ipren
that sort of thing for the seating area
we did change the dimensions a little
bit to
[Music]
maximize the seating area storage and
also to push the walls out and make the
bed longer the bed is actually the thing
I was most excited about for the van
upgrade because we took it from 511 to
6'2 I used to always sleep diagonal on
my bed because I'm 5'9 and I like to
stretch out but now I can actually sleep
sideways and be comfortable we did that
by knocking out the side panels and then
coming up with a new design that can
maximize that space since we changed the
dimensions of the seating area we
couldn't reuse the cushions we had to
custom cut all new cushions but the
benefit of that is I got to choose a new
color the old cushions were a bluish
gray and the new ones are a warm cafe
latte heather gray and I love them the
cushions themselves are 3 in of natural
latex wrapped in Wool batting and
enclosed in a zippered muslin fabric
case which Nest inside this outer casing
of duck canvas with a triple stitch in
seam so it is durable as fun my work
table is mounted on a lagoon Mount and
at night when I make the bed it just
pops right down and then I put these
cushions down over it and lay my 1in
mattress topper on top of the 3 in of
latex cushion so it's super soft it's
probably the size of a full bed I would
say in this bench I keep all of my
bedding and it's pretty deep the 1in
latex mattress topper is down underneath
you can also see my wee boost is tucked
away down here with the interior antenna
mounted to this side column and the
exterior antenna attached to the roof
I've had pretty good luck using this to
boost my cell signal in remote locations
and I recently upgraded my monthly
Mobile plan to include 130 GB hotspot so
I'm able to work off grid in most places
with this setup here's the other end of
that same bench I use a handful of these
zippered linen bags that I got from The
Container Store down inside the benches
cuz they're just super durable and
really great for organization in the
previous build these benches had metal
framing which took up a fair amount of
space so this time around we went with a
simpler design that allows for so much
more storage I've got my backpacking bag
helmet a bunch of hiking boots
underneath the bag is my standup paddle
board which I can easily access from the
back when we redesigned the bed and
dinette area we made it so that the back
bench was actually a lot wider so that
it could serve as a day bed it's 6'2
long and then I think 27 in wide I
personally prefer transforming the whole
Space every single day because it just
makes me feel more productive if I wake
up and the first thing I do is make my
office I go into work mode and that
really helps me with a little bit of
structure and routine but it is nice to
have the option of not having to make my
bed every night this is my work sling
table it can move in all sorts of
directions because it's on a lagoon
Mount this table is a solid piece of
wood as opposed to my last table which
was two pieces of wood glued together
and the problem with that was it was
really thick and heavy and so it would
lean a little bit on the Lagoon Mount
and it had a tendency to warp this one
has not warped at all so so far so
that's been great it's also lighter so
it's less likely to wobble and there's
more surface area so I definitely prefer
this table over the last one if I want
to work from my day bed or have like
dinner in a movie I can reposition the
table like this pull it up close and
then I can have my food my iPad and it's
super convenient I have these two
sliding windows on either side when I'm
sitting at my desk working I have fresh
air coming in I can also look up and see
a beautiful view so that was another
reason why I didn't want a fix bed is
because my desk area would have been
over there and I would have just been
staring at the kitchen sink all day this
may seem like an excessive amount of
pillows in a van this size and it is but
it's storage in plain sight I keep all
my down sleeping bags down jackets and
just other various blankets inside each
of these pillows back here actually one
of you commented on my original van tour
this idea so thank you it has been the
ultimate hack I do have a travel Martin
guitar that I'm still learning how to
play slowly but surely but I usually
just have this in its case and it just
hangs out back there whenever I'm
driving or on the bed if I'm too lazy to
make the bed that
[Music]
day in the back I decided to have
cabinet doors rather than drawers to
save space and added a shelf to the
middle cabinet so I could better
organize my
gear
[Music]
this partition wall used to have an
electric outlet in it which ultimately
resulted in a lot of wasted space I
decided to remove the outlet so we could
open up this wall and create a kind of
cubby hole to hang jackets add a hat
hook and stash a few extra
things my day pack inside my day pack I
have another backpack my grab and go
shower pack shower tote quick dry towel
Carabiner for easy hanging hat storage
laundry bag I've actually had this bag
since College which was well I graduated
in 2007 so a long time okay I know I'm
probably going to get comments asking
about a shower and why I didn't include
one in this rebuild I personally think
that for a van this size a shower just
doesn't make sense to me it's wasted
real estate not only for the shower
stall itself but for the fresh water and
gray water storage as well I actually Ed
my solar shower quite a lot this summer
it's so easy to fill up in a river or
lake and then just add a kettle full of
boiling water to make it nice and hot
plus I have a gym membership sometimes I
house it and there's always campgrounds
and aquatic centers and the occasional
Airbnb so I'm pretty content with this
set up and not having a shower under the
driver's seat I keep a lot of tools and
miscellaneous things like tape and
batteries tire inflator jump starter
shovel I should also probably mention
that we replace the original plastic
cabinet and drawer latches in the van
with a stronger metal latch design so
far it's been a solid upgrade underneath
this swivel passenger seat is my sbar
petrol heater it draws gas directly from
my van's fuel tank so I don't need to
hook up a separate fuel source to keep
it going and it's extremely efficient I
have yet to see any noticeable drop in
the fuel gauge whenever I start the
engine even after using it for hours at
a time also this is the high altitude
model which means it can function in
higher elevations next to the heater I
have a battery powered carbon monoxide
detector and for the rebuild we
relocated the 12vt temperature monitor
to the back of the van so I can easily
start my heater in the morning without
getting out of bed up here in the front
I stack all sorts of miscellaneous
things yoga mat Camp table shoes back
packs walkie-talkies more random stuff
basically I'm like a squirrel and I hide
things everywhere under my cushions I
store my window covers they are from
vanmade gear and they're reflecti
material and they have magnets along the
side so they completely black out the
van once I have them all placed on the
windows and then I have a blackout
curtain here up front that I can secure
to the side door using a magnet so that
there's no light coming out of the van
it's pretty stealthy
I do think this rebuild was absolutely
necessary just to ensure there wasn't
any possibility of mold or wet wood
residual in the van I also wanted to
compensate Brett although he did offer
to do it at Cost which was incredibly
generous of him I didn't want to do that
he put so much work time love and effort
into this van and I'm so so thankful to
him that he even like fit me in I just
passed the 60,000 M Mark in the van
which does seem to surprise a lot of
people considering how long I've been in
the van but doesn't surprise me I mean I
enjoy traveling slow I would say
somewhere around the 2-year Mark of
living like this full-time the novelty
of quickly driving from place to place
kind of wore off and I began to travel
with more intention and base and
locations for weeks at a time before
moving on I find slower travel to be a
lot more enjoyable
and sustainable in the long term I also
really love this van and I want it to
last so I'm not in any rush to rack up
the miles I think overall this layout
really maximizes space it's highly
functional and comfortable while still
being Compact and not a pain to drive
around or park in urban settings or
along narrow mountain roads my only
genuine complaint is that it's not a
4x4 I hope that I cover just about
everything I'm sure I left some things
out here or there so if you have
questions or comments leave them down
below and I will do my very best to
respond come say hi over on Instagram @
Christian Schaefer if you want to see
more behind the scenes content of living
life on the road a full-time as always
thank you so much for being here y'all
are the best maybe one day I'll see you
out on that open
[Music]
road